for centuries the Iron Throne had no
more loyal Ally than the princes of
Dorne since we had never fallen to them
we kept our ancestral title
perhaps this is what Drew rhaegar
Targaryen to us
his Royal parents had not produced a
sister for him to wait so he had to look
elsewhere for a princess
and there was only one in Westeros
Elia of house Martel my sister
she was not the most beautiful woman in
the world or even in Dorne but rare for
a woman from our land her flower came
with no thorns
she was kind and clever with a gentle
heart
I loved her I feared for her
for years I offended off lesser men from
her but when rhaegar came even I failed
he was beautiful and the crowned Prince
of the Seven Kingdoms and our mother had
worked so hard to secure the match how
could Elia not accept him
they were wed and he took her from her
home from those who loved her and would
die for her and locked her in his red
keep above his style of a city
surrounded by false friends
she bore him a daughter and a son though
each almost cost her her life
Elia loved rhaegard she obeyed him and
he chose to steal away lyanna Stark a
pale Northern girl whose veins ran with
ice like other people okay guys house of
the Dragon is based on George R Martin's
book Fire and Blood and now you can
listen to it for free with a notable
trial using her link which you can find
in the description of this video all you
have to do is go to the description
click the link sign up for a free
audible trial and choose Fire and Blood
audiobook go and listen to a complete
Targaryen history including the current
and future events of House of the Dragon
for free instead of disciplining his
faithless son King Ares executed the
Starks when they came Seeking Justice
and ignited a revolt I know how the
maesters described the war now but
calling it Robert's Rebellion does not
change what it was the war of the
usurper
Dorne sided with the crown for when we
swear Oaths we keep them
we needed no threats from King aerys
though he made them anyway locking Elia
and her children in the red keep to
ensure our loyalty
in his madness he knew that no true
dornishmen would ever take up arms
against our beloved princess and that we
would fight to the death for whichever
side she was on
a plan was devised Prince rhaegar would
personally lead the Royal forces now
reinforced with 10 000 dornishmen North
to face Robert of the King's Guard Luan
Mattel and I would ride with the prince
at the Trident Dorne lost ten thousand
men and Two Princes my uncle in the
King's Guard and Elias Gallant husband
prince rhaegar who was too slow or too
arrogant for Robert's Warhammer
as Robert's Army marched on King's
Landing the Mad King sent his own wife
and child away but kept my sister and
hers inside
in his Madness Ares thought that the
dornish had betrayed his son at the
Trident and was only too happy to
welcome his one true friend back into
his ranks
Tywin Lannister
Lord tywin's Army sacked his friend's
City while Lord tywin's son murdered the
king he'd sworn to protect
all this could have been forgiven war is
terrible and men must become terrible to
wage it but the Lannisters knew that as
long as my sister and her children
Prince rhaegar's heirs lived no usurper
could safely sit the throne
so Lord tywin's dog sir Gregor Clegane
the mountain made Elia watch as he
murdered her daughter and dashed her
infant son's head against a wall
then with her baby's blood still on his
hands and murdered her
when Lord Tywin later presented their
bodies to Robert Baratheon wrapped in
pretty Lannister cloaks
and told the red color graciously hid
the blood from men's eyes
the Targaryen stalk of Fire and Blood
endorne our blood is fire
if Robert Baratheon had dared to set
foot in Dorne during his Reign he would
have lost their foot
when I was a boy of 16 a great lord
caught me with his mistress he should
have been honored instead the fat old
fool challenged me to a duel thanks to
my age and Status only to First Blood
but his mistress and his wife warned me
which of my parts he intended to draw
first blood from
he was strong and fierce but slow I cut
him quickly and the duel ended with
honor satisfied
then his wounds festered and he died
ever since men have called me The Red
Viper a name that never fails to draw a
laugh from me as if a single serpent was
all I knew of in him
Westeros has Mighty Rivers but none of
them compare to the roin it is said that
there is no stream or puddle in Western
asses but drains to Mother Roy no doubt
an exaggeration
until one sees the river at its widest a
man in the center can't see a Shore to
either side the greatest of mother
roin's children were the roiner a
civilization as ancient and Grand as old
geese Fishers Traders Scholars workers
of wood Stone and metal the Rhino raised
their elegant cities from the headwaters
of the Rhine down to her mouth each
Lovelier than the last for many
centuries the Rhino lived in relative
peace when Invaders swept down from the
hills the royner woman and man were
Don's silver-scaled armor Fish Head
Helms tall Spears and turtle shell
Shields if the enemy did not laugh
themselves away it was said that mother
Ryan would whisper the enemy's secrets
to her children and the roinish Wizards
could raise watery walls to drown their
foes whatever magic the Royal may have
had it wasn't enough when Valyrian
colonists first arrived the Rhino
embraced them for all men were welcome
to share the Bounty of mother roin
perhaps a water people should have been
more cautious of strangers who exalted
Fire and Blood Legend has it that one
day the valyrians netted and butchered
one of the giant turtles the Rhino held
sacred as a result thousands were killed
or enslaved cities and towns were burned
drowned and rebuilt in these wars the
valerians emerged as Victorious more
often than not the princes of the rohini
Cities fiercely proud of their
independence fought alone whilst the
Valyrian colonies aided one another
eventually the roinish princes ceased
the squabbling and United behind prince
garan who led the largest army essos had
ever seen against a hundred thousand
Valyrian colonists a hundred war
elephants and three dragon Lords
burned but thousands more sheltered in
the shallows of the river whilst the
roinish Wizards raised enormous water
spouts against the first dragons roanish
archers brought down two of the Dragons
whilst the third fled wounded and
thereafter the Ruiner named Garen the
great but mother valyria proved just as
caring as mother Roy when Garen the
great marched his Army against volantis
300 Valyrian dragons descended from the
sky tens of thousands burned whilst
others rushed into the river but the
fires burned so hot that the water
boiled and turned to steam Garen the
great was captured alive and made to
watch as valyrians butchered every last
man so many that their blood turned the
great Harbor of volantis red as far as
the eye could see then they forced Garen
to watch as they marched on his own City
and enslaved all the women and children
his army had left behind the singers
claimed that Prince Garen called out
mother Roy and to curse
and she in turn flooded the city with
foul Waters and a damp fog that caused
the skin of the valyrians to harden and
crack and thus was born grayscale Fury
in a similar fate another roinish ruler
princess naneria led her own people into
every ship skiff and Ralph they had and
fled essos eventually after much
hardship they landed in sunswept and
bone dry Dawn but we all know that Tale
she was lucky to land in Dorne where
powerful women are not locked away in
seps and the beds of old men
my ancestor Morris Martell saw her and
desired her and proved that where armies
fail a tongue may succeed wedding his
strength to hers his spear to her son
they subdued all his Rivals together
after the tradition of her people house
Martell then ruled Dorne as princes not
Kings unless the eldest child was a
daughter for unlike the rest of Westeros
we follow a prince or a princess Martel
just the same and we always have some
people forget that aegon Targaryen
crowned himself Lord of six kingdoms not
seven
when his sister marched on Dorne she
found no Mighty hosts drawn up against
her for her Dragon to burn in her
soldiers to slaughter
the Sans swirled men died and her Dragon
saw nothing
the sun Shone man died and her Dragon
bowed to our greater fire
the targaryens retreated with their
tails tucked between their legs
of course in later years his descendants
would try again
they run the first succeeded at Great
cost and reigned in Dorne for a few
glorious months
one night his Steward pulled down a sash
by his bed to summon his consorts
instead the canopy split open and a
hundred red scorpions fell on him he was
a Tyrell you would think he would be
used to getting stung
within a fortnight house Martel again
ruled a free door as I said for free you
can now listen to the entire audiobook
Fire and Blood On which house of the
Dragon is based and which covers the
entire Targaryen history including
current and future events of House of
the Dragon for free with a notable trial
using our Link in the description
thank you